in 1188 king henry ii of england
welcomed some of his nobles to join him
at a feast
to celebrate the completion of his great
castle at dover towering over the white
cliffs that guard the coast of england
henry had spent a fortune during the
previous decade building this castle
about 8 000 pounds on the construction
it's about 10 million in today's dollars
his total annual revenue was only about
thirteen thousand pounds
this castle was strategically placed on
the coast and it was a showcase of
technology
i want to dedicate a lecture on life in
the great medieval palaces for several
reasons
first of course the palace architecture
is a recognizable feature of medieval
life that survives today
but the buildings and the life within
reveals much more we are what we consume
our choices of buildings and spaces
clothing food tells us much about the
values we hold
that's true today
and it was true in the middle ages so
let's look at medieval values through
daily life
to begin
i will start with henry's court in dover
the great tower in the center of the
fortified castle
had three floors
and the second floor housed the great
hall where the nobles gathered
the great hall was the most public space
of the castle
here was where the king transacted
business held entertainments
and eight formal meals
the hall had a high and low end and the
royalty sat at a raised dais where all
could see them
after that the nobles arranged
themselves in order of rank down the
table
the legend of king arthur's round table
was intended to show that all knights
were equal
but in reality hierarchy was preserved
in the great halls of the castles men
and women alike shared the great banquet
the queen and her ladies joined the king
on the deus at the high part of the
table the area of honor and the queen's
throne matched henry's in size in fact
when the lords of the castles were away
as they often were during local wars or
long-distance crusading women presided
the ever-present warfare in the west
gave noble women considerable power
even less powerful women than queen
eleanor ruled their own castles and
their own lands
however this autonomy didn't mean that
women were equal when the lord was back
in town he was in charge
men and women alike were fashionable
clothing appropriate to their rank
since the crusades in the 11th century
silks and exotic furs found their way to
the chest of the nobility
women often wore makeup powdering their
faces and they curled their hair with
hot irons
unlike the nobility in other parts of
the world who were more conservative in
their dress
people in europe embraced shifting
fashions
as the nobility wanted to signal their
ability to wear new dramatic looks
one 12th century commentator lamented
the old way of dressing has been almost
completely thrown over by the new
inventions
women changed their dresses revealing
the tops of their breasts and changed
their hair coverings from modest scarves
to elaborate hats
men too changed their look
by the 14th century a critic wrote that
men wore tunics so short and tight that
they revealed what modesty bids us hide
some historians have drawn conclusions
from clothing to values
by arguing that changes in fashion
mark a society that is open to change
and creativity if this is so the
medieval west was prepared for
innovation
as the nobility gathered in the hall
they showed a range of fabrics colors
furs and style
the hall had an open hearth
where a fire burned for light and heat
and smoke filled the room drifting out
through the small slits in the stone
walls
there was no glass covering the windows
and in the cold north the wind blew in
unimpeded
by the 13th century fireplaces were
invented to clear the air from the rooms
and the middle of the 15th century
edward iv added a fireplace to the dover
castle hall but in the 12th century the
smoke filled the room as servants
brought food up from the great kitchens
below
what did the nobility eat
bread was a staple food and was
invariably present at meals
loaves of bread were placed on the table
and slices of bread were used as plates
but the heart of the aristocratic diet
was meat
the europeans ate more meat per capita
throughout the middle ages than did
anyone else in the world
servants would bring large plates of
roasted or boiled meat as well as fish
and people would eat with knives and
spoons no forks were used
though europeans ate the most meat they
were choosier than most other peoples on
what kind of meat they ate
in general christian europe prohibited
the eating of carnivores this eliminated
dogs wolves bears and cats from their
diet
they made an exception for the
omnivorous pigs in large part
because jews and muslims refused to eat
pork so christians wanted to set
themselves apart
they also refused to eat horse meat
because that was associated with nordic
pagan religious customs yet
this left plenty of meat for the table
beef pork all kinds of foul and deer and
other game
there was plenty of game because the
serfs were forbidden to hunt on their
land
though there were always poachers to try
to supplement the peasant diet with a
rabbit or two
their vegetables were used as seasonings
onions leeks cabbages garlic turnips and
parsnips graced the dishes and northern
fruits like apples pears and berries
were available
the diet of the peasants was actually
better than that of the nobility if they
had enough to eat
they were more likely to consume their
grains boiled in gruel instead of bread
and they depended more heavily on beans
and milk products as protein sources
they ate cheeses as well as milk and
eggs and relied heavily on vegetables to
fill out their diet
peasants didn't eat at tables like the
nobility they sat on stools by the fire
as they held their bowls in their laps
the servants working in the great hall
of the castles had to wait until the
nobility had finished their several
courses before they ate
the nobility loved wine and imported it
from france spain portugal and even as
far away as greece
and henry ii could easily have served
wine liberally to his guests
most wines were most often drunk young
because they did not keep as well as
modern wines
while wine was always valued the staple
drink was ale that is unhopped beer
without the preservative quality of the
hops the beer did not keep well so women
had to brew regularly
the beer was not as alcoholic as modern
broods and that's probably a good thing
since daily intake was substantial
it is a long-standing story that ancient
people drank beer because the water was
bad
this is a myth
in most places the water was much better
than ours since they had not polluted
rivers and well water
plenty of people drank water but others
drank beer
because they liked it
the records of the houses of the
aristocracy allow for one gallon per
person
and peasant households allowed for two
to four pints daily
people also made hard cider from apples
and perry from pears
they also fermented honeycombs into
fermented mead
after dinner and entertainment the king
and his wife retreated to their private
quarter upstairs though private is a
relative term and modern notions of
privacy didn't exist in the middle ages
the royal couple had curtains that
surrounded their bed as much for warmth
in the drafty castle as for privacy
servants slept in the room and waited on
the royal couple
there within the castle they would be
relatively safe
the castle itself had concentric walls
to prevent invaders
and was built over a well to provide
water during long sieges
europe was dotted with fortified palaces
for the homes of the nobility served as
both homes and military fortifications
why were there so many fortified castles
in europe
many areas were on shifting borders that
required guarding for example the border
between england and wales had many
castles in spain as the christians
slowly reconquered their lands from the
muslims in the south they built castles
to secure their advances
in addition
there was always internal fighting
henry ii who proudly built dover castle
fought wars against his sons including
richard the lionhearted
castles were designed to allow the
nobility to sleep well
if often in cold drafty accommodations
in times of military insecurity
these castles stood as marvels of
engineering and have become defining
characteristics of the medieval west
these structures
also took their toll on the environment
as great forests were cleared of timber
to shore up the stones as workmen built
for example records show that in the
castle of windsor in england it required
the wood of more than four thousand oak
trees in its construction
as castles rose all over europe their
stone towers replaced many forests as
prominent features in the landscape
as we move to the palaces of the wealthy
and other parts of the world we will not
see the stone fortresses that
characterized western europe
many of the wealthy and rulers chose to
live in cities these cities were
protected by great stone walls leaving
the palaces designed with comfort in
mind
when we turn to the islamic world we
have to rely primarily on written
descriptions to see medieval palaces
it was customary for new rulers to
destroy the palaces of their
predecessors and build new buildings
the only medieval muslim palace still
standing is the famous alhambra built in
the 14th century in granada spain
let me recreate life as it would have
been lived in these muslim palaces
a visitor coming to a muslim palace
first entered a compound within a high
wall with elaborate doors
within he entered a great courtyard
which served as a common area
where guests were welcomed and
entertained
there were also various adjacent gardens
that also served as entertaining spaces
or retreats for the family
courtyards were often very elaborate
with fountains gardens and canopies and
trellises that allowed in light but
provided cooling shade
palaces were usually made of stone or
brick though sometimes wood was used and
the interiors were decorated with the
same kinds of patterned tiles and
carvings that graced the mosques since
even in their homes muslims avoided
graven images
this style of housing originated in the
warm south concerned more with capturing
cooling breezes and shade
but it was less effective in the north
in the turkish lands which can be cold
there were no fireplaces the only
heating was a small brazier which could
burn a little charcoal
in persia there were fireplaces but they
were very narrow so wood would be burned
standing on its end to save on wood
nor were there fireplaces in india
in the cold weather guests would be
entertained indoors in rooms adjacent to
a courtyard and provided with woven
blankets
as guests gathered there were no women
present
due to strict segregation palaces had
separate women's quarters called harems
where only women children family members
and eunuchs could enter the koran
permitted muslim men to have four wives
but rulers also had many concubines so
the palaces had large areas devoted to
the women's quarters
while women were excluded from a public
life they exerted political skills
within the harem to forward the fortunes
of their sons
as male visitors gathered either in the
courtyard or an adjacent room for a meal
they sat on rugs and cushions arrayed on
the floor
one of the significant differences in
daily life between the west and the rest
of the world
is the seating position
in most parts of the world people did
not sit on chairs
instead they squatted or sat
cross-legged on the floor a position
that europeans found difficult
so the furniture surrounding the dinner
was sparse
though the magnificent woolen carpets
sometimes were piled up and soft
cushions gave the guests support
sometimes low tables were set up and
large copper trays balanced on wooden
frames might be brought out
the food was arrayed of the trays in the
center from which people served
themselves using hands spoons or knives
muslims had dietary restrictions
their meat had to be halal lawful and
permissible
meat had to come from animals that were
slaughtered properly with no remaining
blood
and carrion and pork were forbidden
muslim rulers in india would confront
mutual suspicion in the dietary patterns
of the hindus they ruled
muslims ate beef which was forbidden to
hindus and hindus ate pork unclean to
muslims
these dietary differences have caused
problems into the 21st
century muslims were permitted to eat
all seafood and enjoyed a wide variety
of cheeses and yogurts
since muslim traders brought spices from
the indian ocean trade many spices were
available in the palaces of baghdad and
beyond
medieval muslim cookbooks recommended
using liberal quantities of pepper
nutmeg
cinnamon musk ginger and cloves for the
sophisticated palettes of the rich
in fact
if rulers in the west showed off their
wealth and power by their fashionable
clothing
these rulers could point to the
delicacies on their table as proof of
their prosperity
a great treat for the rich was snow
water
purchased from snow vendors who brought
snow from the mountains and sold it for
exorbitant prices
farmers in southern spain would
sometimes fill their wells with snow
from the mountains so they could sell it
to their muslim rulers in the summer
imagine it like a snow cone with a bit
of fruit juice or honey poured on it
delicious
what did our palace visitors drink with
their elaborate meal
the quran prohibits drinking wine or
other intoxicating beverages
so wine was not served
we will leave aside the many times that
less observant muslims enjoyed wine
and even wrote poems extolling its
virtues
observant muslims drank a range of near
beers and other lightly fermented drinks
and scholars debated of how lightly a
drink might be fermented and still be
permitted
beyond these drinks
cooks prepared varied fruit juices
mixing lemons oranges apples tamarinds
dates grapes pomegranates and many
others
within the religious frameworks that
muslims observed they nevertheless
enjoyed a great diversity of food and
drink on the palace table
let's move further east and look at life
in china's palaces where wealth and
traditions shape their lives in ways
very different from europe and the
muslim world
in the 12th century the chinese imperial
palace was on a mountain called phoenix
mountain located on the edge of west
lake in hangzhou the capital
the palace was destroyed in 1276
after the fall of the dynasty
although rulers of different dynasties
built palaces for their own use
the building style remain the same
when it comes to housing people are
remarkably conservative they tend to
preserve traditions so their homes are
both familiar and provide a continuity
with the past
and chinese palaces exemplify this
tendency
we can see what medieval palaces look
like as we admire the forbidden city in
beijing where the ming dynasty
established its capital in 1403
and from which emperors ruled until 1912
while the forbidden city is modeled on
previous palaces it's much larger it has
980 buildings and covers 180 acres it is
said to have
9999 rooms just short of the reputed 10
000 rooms that exist in heaven
as the palace was the next best thing to
heaven which was a peaceful and ordered
place
the palace of the song and subsequent
dynasties was arranged to embody
confucian principles to bring hierarchy
and order to this world
there was no glass for the windows they
covered them with silk or other cloth
that might let in the light
a visitor would first enter the gate in
the walls surrounding the palace he
would see that it was not a house at all
but a great complex designed to house
families
there were many rectangular halls that
faced south to catch the warmth of the
sun and the blessings of fire
the halls made of wood for good luck
surrounded various courtyards and
gardens
and since fire was always a hazard of
wooden buildings the roofs were ceramic
and they often sported fish on the eaves
to ward off fire
visitors would not expect to meet the
wives and concubines of the emperor
nor of any wealthy person's household
for that matter
like in muslim homes the women were
secluded to remain in the inner rooms
new brides entered the household
never to leave again and to live in
obedience to their mothers-in-law
a wife had no status until she bore a
son and her only hope for an improved
life in the future
was to become mother of an emperor or
lord of the land
the seclusion of women was insured with
a cruel practice that extended into the
20th century
foot binding
young girls at about six years old were
taken in hand by their mothers
their toes were folded in and bent and
the arch of their feet were broken and
bound
they were forced to walk to further
break the bones until they were reshaped
into a wedge form called golden lotus
that might be as small as five inches
bound feet made a woman eligible for a
good marriage with nobility or even
wealthy merchants who wanted to copy the
lifestyle of the old families
later into the modern era this practice
even extended into the countryside where
peasant girls had their feet bound so
they would sit and weave and spin all
day
why did this crippling practice endure
for so long
historians have a number of answers
in part it was part of the confucian
ideal embraced by the song emperors that
demonstrated women's obedience to ideals
of subservience to duty and husbands
chinese sources claimed that the bound
feet were sexually exciting
some claimed that the swaying walk
required by the bound feet caused
buttocks thigh muscles and vagina to
remain tight this explanation doesn't
make sense to me because for muscles to
tighten
women would have to walk even with their
swaying gait and these crippled women
walked very little
if they had to go any distance at all
they were carried on the backs of
servants
perhaps simply the idea of the painful
renunciation the women experienced was
erotic enough
in any case these women with bound feet
remained enclosed in the women's
quarters
at feasts a host might provide the
company of courtesans whose feet were
also bound but who were there to provide
entertainment
unlike in the west where fashions
changed rapidly
wealthy chinese proudly wore the kind of
voluminous layers of robes that had been
popularized during the tang dynasty and
probably earlier
societies that preserve old ways of
dressing
likewise proudly preserve their heritage
and that gives legitimacy to their
present
it's this kind of conservativism that
caused practices like foot binding to
last so long
the confucian insistence on respect for
elders caused people to respect the past
however the chinese did at times accept
one innovation from the west
chairs
unlike people in the middle east or
india and south asia the chinese
embraced both sitting on the floor with
cushions
and at times providing chairs
and higher tables
they seem to have imported the idea of
chairs sometime in the early tang
dynasty probably in the 7th century and
they were called barbarian couches
and recognition of their origins outside
china
probably throughout the middle ages
chairs were reserved for the powerful or
perhaps the old
and what did the chinese serve at their
banquet the quick answer is they ate
almost everything especially animal
protein and the more elaborate the feast
the more exotic the dishes
servants brought in an array of dishes
that were placed on low tables for
people to reach in and sample with their
chopsticks
chopsticks began to be widely used in
china at the beginning of the middle
ages in about 400 ce
before that people used knives and
spoons as they did in the west but there
were a couple of reasons for chinese
adoption of chopsticks
we have seen that the abundant harvests
of rice caused a population boom
but there was a shortage of satisfying
protein
cooks began to chop meat into small
pieces to make it go further these small
pieces also had the advantage of cooking
quickly saving fuel
the spread of confucian ideology also
promoted the use of chopsticks the sage
who was a vegetarian believed that
knives had no place at the table because
the blades reminded people of the
slaughterhouse and its violence and he
believed that would interrupt the gentle
mood that was to prevail at the meal
the use of chopsticks
spread through east and southeast asia
so diners carefully reached for the
chopped tidbits with their chopsticks
and always had bowls of rice to
accompany the proteins and boiled greens
cooks used all kinds of ingredients many
westerners find shocking
recipes from as early as the tang
dynasty which became the model for
subsequent cooks
reveal the astonishing array of foods
pork was the most popular beet but
northerners also ate camels especially
the hump carefully boiled
boiled bear bamboo rats sea otters or
nicely fried flying cockroaches
in the south
cooks prepared elephants slaying with
poison arrows monkeys
and every kind of snake
python hash flavored with vinegar was a
delicacy
they ate all fish
from poison puffer fish that needs
careful preparation even today
to horseshoe crabs boiled into a sauce
people loved all kinds of fruits and
farmers imported mangoes figs citrus
fruits and many more
i could list many more delicacies but
perhaps this list gives you an idea of
the array of foods
that grace their tables
what drinks accompanied these feasts
the chinese gave a lot of attention to
the water they drank
one medical text
described the virtues of 26 different
kinds of water
from rain
to water fountain pig troughs which
would heal snake bites if applied to the
wound
they also added fruit juices to flavor
the various waters
from the 6th century
tea was a popular drink at the tables of
the wealthy
of course the chinese also enjoyed
alcoholic beverages which were offered
at the table
while they had imported grapes for wine
that remained a rare treat
the real drink of choice for the men
from the tang dynasty until today was
rice wine
this was fermented grains
millet in the north and rice in the
south and it took skilled brewers to
make this
these rice wines were often flavored
with things like black pepper or fruit
juices
after a satisfying hours-long feast
accompanied by music
the emperor or other wealthy host
retired to his own quarters in the
compound
the men seldom stayed with their wives
the women were brought to his bedroom
for sexual intercourse
the man slept among his cushions and
furs surrounded by his servants who
slept on the floor of his room
this sample of medieval daily life can
show us the ways in which humans are
alike and how they're different
as we study the material life of the
past
we can see the things we use from the
houses that give us shelter to the food
that sustains us the clothes that
protect us and the items that amuse us
in every society we need all these
things and the differences that emerge
arise in large part
from the goods that were locally
accessible
vikings built with sod because they had
no wood
and societies that had a shortage of
wood
didn't use fireplaces
people who kept sheep wore wool
and those who had silk worms wore silk
the same principle applies to food
all over the world people seek out what
constitutes a balanced diet
we all want grains or some other
starches fruits and vegetables and
protein
societies like china that have a lot of
people and not much protein must eat
everything
locations like europe that actually had
more domestic animals than people
could afford to be choosy
beyond the basics another overriding
reality of humans
is the desire for fermented beverages
these are practical because they form a
way to preserve foods grains or grapes
but our desire goes beyond that
we like beverages
and other plants from tobacco to cava to
marijuana all available in the middle
ages that change our moods
the history of human diet tells us a lot
about our culture we are indeed
what we eat
finally this brief survey
shows us that humans are desperately
greedy for innovation
in our food we long for novelty which
established a valuable trade in things
like pepper or spices to change our
flavors and this is the same impulse
that will send christopher columbus
looking for the spice islands
in clothing the silk trade also brought
huge wealth
we don't need jewels artwork and other
items of beauty but we sure want them
and as we have seen throughout this
course this desire led to global trade
and great wealth
that was true in the middle ages and
it's true today